it's as human as it comes preparing food
for your people but in times of droughts
just getting to the point of adding
water to the vegetables takes formidable
effort
I meet with a family in the village of
antara nomadio who tell me this pumping
station was built by the government to
bring water up from the Mandalay River
five kilometers away
but in two decades the valves haven't
opened the tank was never filled because
the pipes were never laid
the liberal trucks and materials and
built it but then went away and never
came back
the art is Dane's family has taken
residence in the pump house but because
of the drought they've had to sell their
possessions in order to eat
and now every day all ages set off to
find water on the long walk to the
Mandarin River and this is what tens of
thousands of people across the region do
it's often a journey of several hours
there and back
I went along with suenzui and his
brothers the wind is searing and the sun
saps your energy
and they do this day after day after day
we passed young children doing their bit
for the village
and after two long hours we arrive at
the river it's murky waters are
life-saving
and containers are filled
remember now they have to return with 20
sometimes 40 liters of water on their
backs
we've never experienced anything like
this it's a very very hard situation
there are no Seasons anymore it's just
hot dry and windy that's why we have to
come here to take water from the river
even the river has run dry in recent
years but rain in the farm mountains has
replenished its flow
and they come
man and Beast
so this is effectively the kitchen tap
for thousands and thousands of people
people have walked for hours just to get
their supplies
water for washing
water for cooking
and water for drinking
and so the Journey Back Home up the
valley begins and in the Resolute
determination of the villagers you may
Wonder at the Injustice of it all people
that did nothing to make global warming
happen being forced to live like this
year after remorseless year
Nick Clark Al Jazeera the grand suit
Madagascar